when they say are we want equality it's
like what does equality look like when I
do half of the Brick Lane half of the
plumbing half of the electric yeah
no they're doing loads of sewage
rebuilding aren't they in London at the
moment so maybe women could get on board
with that oh yeah
I'll sit in the kitchen cooking I used
to do three meals I used to work in
construction the majority of the
employees are men so it's like party
it's like I think it's 98 then in all
those fields yeah the women usually take
on the admin rooms it's not usually the
hard labor which they're they're more
most of them are more than able to do it
but they don't want to